hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the most central concepts running
throughout
the entirety of chapter three of john
stuart mill's work
on liberty is that of individuality at
certain times he'll also talk about
originality but he has the same thing in
mind and it
is indeed centered on the individual
as the subject as the bearer of it but
it has
wide implications particularly given
his advocacy of the importance of
cultivation of individuality and there's
several different aspects involved
here one would be in terms of the
individual
reading jon stewart mill's argument they
might say oh
i been misliving my life i need to
start focusing on other things and
cultivating myself and
mill would certainly be quite happy to
see that going on
but he's making a larger argument
in the entire work about the extent to
which
the government or society
or pick whatever other coercive
uh imposing force you would like is
legitimately concerned to control
to protect to punish to
bring power to bear upon people
and one corollary of his
harm principle enunciated earlier in the
work
is that really these forces shouldn't
stand in the way
of the cultivation of individuality and
if they were
indeed working for the benefit of
society they would encourage
the cultivation of individuality a case
which does not hold
according to mill in most societies
except accidentally and which he is
trying to argue a case for
in his own time a case that's relevant
to our own time
so midway through the chapter he's got
this great phrase where he says that
individuality is the same thing
with development and is only
it is only the cultivation of
individuality
which produces well-developed human
beings
so it is possible to live a human life
as
a rational animal the kind of thing that
we are
without having fully or even to some
degree
gone down the road of developing our
individuality of developing ourselves we
can
live in a you could say diminished
state so in order to become a
well-developed human being
we really do need to cultivate our
individuality and that may not be
viable for some people given their
socioeconomic or other
statuses but mill is saying that this is
really
absolutely central and he advocates
something like
an aesthetics of the human person
and their development itself running
throughout this chapter
a point made at so many different
passages
and places that we don't really need to
belabor instead
let's think about what he has to say in
this chapter
answering this key question without ever
raising the question as such and
centering in on it but providing
answers to it at different points we can
ask
all right so if cultivation of
individuality
is such an important thing what's
involved there
what's required what what do we have to
do
in order if we want to cultivate our
individuality or
create space opportunities for others to
do the same
what's needed and he gives a number of
different
answers one of which is primarily
negative and this is one that has drawn
some criticism
by later commentators who think that
perhaps he goes a little bit too far but
in this work at least he is
very clear that
it requires that the person not be
determined not take their cues
largely from and he uses a couple
different terms here
uh tradition or custom custom is a word
that comes up a lot in this case and we
could understand this as the
social mores the web of expectations
that you know govern our
life that tell us who's a good person
who's a bad person who's in group who's
out group
so take for example something like
picking your nose
picking your nose in public right we
view that as
uh disgusting behavior for the most part
we make fun of people
who do that there are cartoon characters
that we see with their fingers all the
way up their nose we make
memes of people we even associate
things that come out of your nose with
grossness you know for example
when one of the presidential candidates
in a recent election campaign
had a bit of stuff come out of his nose
and stick i think to his lip
people went went crazy about it now is
mill saying oh
abandon that custom pick your nose as
much as you like
not exactly but at least this gives us
an idea
about what a social mores or social more
uh
most or actually in latin maurice is the
plural of it would look
like but we could think about other
things as well like
do we form a line do we not form a line
you know these things that we call
etiquette and how we address people in
emails
all of these these sorts of things it's
not to say that a person won't respect
social mores
but they need to do so through their own
choice not just because it is what is
done
it is what is expected so that's a
rather
negative negatively phrased negatively
understood negatively conceptualized
way of talking about this you take away
the force the determining force of these
things
and substitute something else in its
place
mill uses this term spontaneity early on
now when we think about spontaneity we
think about on the spot
making a decision having a response
you know grand romantic gestures could
be spontaneous
and he he does have in mind those as
perhaps a subclass but
a much broader
set of responses choices determinations
made by ourselves coming out
of ourselves another word for this
could be authenticity or
even to some degree autonomy
and he talks about using and
interpreting experience so this is
actually
a good place to pick this up you know
and this is coming back to the notion
of tradition when we listen to what
other people have to say
about um things very often they're
they're on point
so he says uh here we go it would be
absurd to pretend people ought to
live as if nothing would ever had been
known in the world before they came into
it
as if experience has has yet done
nothing
towards showing that one mode of
existence or conduct is preferable to
another
nobody denies that people should be so
taught and trained in youth
as to know and benefit from by the
ascertained results of human experience
but it is the privilege and proper
condition of a human being
arrived at the maturity of his faculties
to use
and interpret experience in his own
way it is for him to find out what part
of recorded experience is properly
applicable
to his own circumstances and character
traditions and customs of other people
are to a certain extent evidence of what
their experience has taught them
presumptive evidence and as such have a
claim to his deference
but in the first place their experience
the experience of those of the past
may be too maybe too narrow or they may
not have interpreted it rightly
secondly their interpretation may be
correct but unsuitable to him customs
are made for
customary circumstances and customary
characters
and his circumstances or his character
may be uncustomary third
though the customs may be good as
customs and suitable to him
to conform to custom merely as custom
does not educate or develop in him
any the qualities which are the
distinctive endowments of a human being
so
you know being able to interpret
experience in our own
way this is something that is valuable
for us
and needful for us and it's part of how
we get away from
or at least get some distance from
tradition and custom
making choices is also a
central part of this he's got this great
phrase here the human
faculties of perception judgment
discriminative feeling mental
activity and even moral preference are
exercised
only in making a choice
it is through making choices and perhaps
getting things wrong
that we are developing our individuality
out of our own character through our own
choices this is uh very important so
this is spontaneity is not simply just
doing random stuff it's this capacity
to do things that flow out of ourselves
and that we ourselves choose
he also talks about cultivating
not just one's own understanding
and not just one's will which is in
large part in this essay
connected with conscience the will holds
one
back rather than just doing everything
whatsoever
but also our desires and
impulses things that do appear you know
rather spontaneous
but which we might view as in some
respects
less ourselves and less dignified he
says desires
and impulses are as much a part of a
perfect human being
as beliefs and restraints
strong impulses are only perilous when
not properly balanced
when one set of aims and inclinations is
developed into strength while others
which ought to coexist with them remain
weak and inactive
it is not because men's desires are
strong that they act ill
it is because their consciences are weak
so you know we should in fact try to
develop
our desires and inclinations but we have
to do so in a certain
framework and here is where we get to
another really
important part and great insight on
mill's part
of this having to do with our what we
can call our
social nature so he says
it's not by wearing down into uniformity
all that's individual in themselves but
by cultivating and calling it
forth that human beings become a noble
and beautiful object of contemplation
now there's a phrase that i just left
out there
within the limits imposed
by the rights and interests of
others so
cultivating yourself as an individual
means recognizing that you exist within
a social
fabric of other individuals and you
can in fact transgress against them
against their
rights against their interests you could
be a sadist
and derive pleasure by the many
different
modes of experimentation of imposing
pain
or humiliation upon other people
but would that really be cultivation of
your
own individuality yes but in a twisted
way
for mill and by
not respecting the rights and interests
of others you actually
damage yourself he says that
as the works partake the character of
those who do them by the same process
human life also becomes rich diversified
in animating
furnishing more abundant element to high
thoughts and elevating feelings
strengthening the tie
which binds every individual to the race
the human race by making the race
infinitely better worth belonging to
in proportion to the development of his
individuality each person becomes
more valuable to himself and therefore
capable of being more valuable
to others so we we're naturally
if we're cultivating ourselves going to
be other
oriented he says a little bit further
as much compression is necessary to
prevent the stronger specimens of human
nature from encroaching on the
rights of others cannot be dispensed
with but for this there is
ample compensation even in the point of
view of human development
the means of development by which the
individual loses
by being prevented from gratifying his
inclinations to the injury of others
are chiefly obtained at the expense of
the development of other people
even to himself there is a full
equivalent in the better development of
the social part of his nature
rendered possible by this the restraint
put on
the selfish part so we become
not just better morally but fuller
human beings by actually
respecting the rights of others by
exercising
control over ourselves when we're
tempted
to transgress against them and this
leads us to this
great ideal of development that mill
articulates for what cultivation of
individuality
looks like great energies
guided by vigorous reason and strong
feelings guided by a conscientious
will so the person is not an
atrophied you know sort of everything
below rationality and will
shrunken in disciplined taken away
sort of person it's a person who
actually has
all of the parts all of the portions of
human nature
operating at full capacity and doing so
in a harmonious way
which will include some tensions within
the person
but which are going to be guided by
rationality or
understanding and will these two
higher faculties of the human being
which are also what are developed
through the cultivation of
individuality the last thing that we
have to say here
is that it may sound as if mill is
putting forth
a single model or ideal for what this
person looks like and he's very
clear that that is not the case
he tells us that
here we go there's no reason all human
existence
should be constructed on some one or
some small number of
patterns if a person possesses any
tolerable amount of common sense and
experience
his own mode of laying out his existence
is the best not because it is the best
in itself
but because it is his own mode human
beings are not like sheep
and even sheep are not indistinguishably
alike and he
talks about you know clothing fitting us
and he says that different persons
require different conditions
for their spiritual development and can
no more exist healthily
in the same moral than all the variety
of plants can in the same physical
atmosphere
and climate the same things which are
helps to one person towards the
cultivation of this higher nature
are hindrances to another and so
in order to develop as he says are
mental moral and aesthetic
faculties bring them to the degree that
they're capable of
there is no one single recipe for how
this ought to be done
and the individual will themself
have to take a very active role in
determining
how best to cultivate their own
individuality it doesn't mean that they
will go without guides
entirely but they themselves
have to be relatively autonomous
and as their individuality develops they
may engage in some
processes of checking in and you know
checking the progress of some things and
readjusting and
doing all those sorts of things so that
is what mill
envisions as a cultivation of
individuality
you